a Chris knife is a milk-white curved and
double edged knife made from the tooth
of an Arrakis desert worm to the desert
people of Arrakis the Fremen
a Chris knife is sacred if the blade was
drawn it could not be received until it
had drawn blood and the blade was not to
be seen by outsiders of the tribe
otherwise the people would either be
killed or cleansed in a ritual the
sharpness of the blades is said to be
unparalleled and they even glow in dull
light in Doom the Chris knife is
referred to as the fabled Chris knife of
Arrakis the blade that had never been
taken off the planet and was known only
by rumor and wild gossip
the Furhman are a group of people who
live in the deserts of Arrakis the
actual population of the Fermin had been
greatly underestimated by the Imperium
before the events of doom much of rim
and culture is dominated by the fight
for survival due to the brutal
conditions of the planet Arrakis the
environmental realities of the planet
brought about the necessity for sparse
use of resources and energy especially
water in fact much of Furman culture is
based around the preservation of water
also the Freeman's long history with
persecution demanded the need for
refined combat knowledge these are the
major two aspects responsible for the
development of the Fremen culture and
their emergence as efficient and Hardy
warriors who use their own skills while
working in tangent with the environment
of the planet Arrakis to fend off
opponents who often possess far superior
formal training and technology the
Furman people came to Arrakis thousands
of years before the events of dune they
were the zen suni wanderers a set of
religious people in retreat from
persecution on the planet poor Turan of
people that would later become the
Furman had grown soft due to the easy
conditions of their planet this however
made them an easy target for Imperial
Raiders slave colonies were planted on
the planets Mellott a goose and SaLuSa
secundus the Fremen eventually spread to
other planets including harmon tap
before eventually stopping on dune
though poor Turin is considered by some
to be the original Planet of the Fremen
it is said in terminology of the
Imperium but there are clues in their
language and mythology that show far
more ancient planetary roots the Firman
people are organized into groups
communities called CJIs each seat is
built within one of the numerous rocky
formations that exist sporadically
throughout the sands of Arrakis leading
each seat is an eon a leader who ascends
to his position by challenging his
predecessor in combat thus proving
himself the strongest member of the
tribe the fuhrmann justice system also
primarily relies on trial by combat
the Fremen are some of the best
hand-to-hand warriors in the entire
universe the harsh conditions of the
planet doom have forced them to be so in
the first book in the series Paul
Atreides teaches the Fremen warriors the
weirding way and with this they are able
to overthrow the imperial sardick our
soldiers who were previously unbeatable
as I mentioned earlier water also played
a vital role in Furman culture to the
Fremen people of Arrakis water was truly
life there was almost no water on the
surface of Arrakis for this reason
Freeman's survival demanded that they
conserve against the unnecessary loss of
water at all cost
all freeman we're still suits which are
full-body filtration systems which
reclaim the body's water the wearer of a
still suit would lose only a thimbleful
of water per day and be able to survive
for four weeks in the open desert
without the still suit a person would
die in the desert Sun within hours in
Furman culture the water of each
person's body belongs to the tribe when
a freeman dies the tribe conserves their
water by distilling it from the dead
body the Fremen use wind traps to
collect water from their atmosphere this
water is preserved in underground caches
each Freeman child develops the eyes of
Avadh before they reach adolescence
these blue within blue eyes are due to
their excessive ingestion of the spice
melange
it is the marker of spice addiction this
cannot be avoided for people living in
the deep desert the Furman are also a
deeply spiritual people and very
superstitious since they have men on
Arrakis they have adapted their Zen
Sunni faith to the desert environment of
the planet the great sand worm of the
planet doom is to the Fremen known as
shy allude the worms were believed to be
the physical manifestations of God
thus the worms are worshiped by the
Freeman people much of the Fremen belief
system was based upon prophecy and the
Bene Gesserit sisterhood is responsible
for sowing the seeds of a significant
portion of freeman legends and myths
each Freeman seat has a Saiga Dena a
wise woman
a rogue Reverend Mother who possessed
some of the talents of the Bene Jesuit
Reverend mother's due to the mission or
protect Eva the saya Deena is a
significant part of freman spiritual
traditions
there are also various Islamic
undertones an Arabic etymologies found
in Fremen culture and throughout dim the
planet known as Arrakis seems to be
derived from the Arabic word for dancer
which derives from Rex with the added to
the beginning
it becomes Arrakis the dancer it may
also be possible that the name Arrakis
derives from the arabic iraqis meaning
the cheapest or of least worth this
seems accurate considering the fact that
before the discovery of spice melange
the planet was of no real value the
death commanders which paul trains known
as the fate Akeem get their name from
the Arabic word fayeen which in the time
that dune was being written was the term
used for Palestinian guerrilla warriors
many other words and names in the series
are Arabic in origin Frank Herbert based
the Fremen culture in part on the
Bedouin people who have historically
inhabited the desert regions of the
Arabian Peninsula Iraq and northern
Africa the English word Bedouins comes
from the Arabic baduy meaning desert
dweller Frank Herbert also based the
Fremen in part on Warwick's the nomadic
people who principally inhabit the
Sahara Desert in dune the Fremen people
are survivors
they have persevered through persecution
and managed to topple their enemies
though at a great cost
[Music]
[Music]
in Frank Herbert's 1960 sci-fi series
dune the Tleilaxu are an extremely
secretive group of humans who live on
the planet to laylax which is the only
planet circling the star thalam that
laylax ooh our genetically altered and
in